Hi, everybody. Welcome to the cold open of this episode of SmartList.
I'm freezing.
You know, it'd be great if Arnette was here to warm this cold open up a little bit.
I don't think he's available.
No, he's not available.
We should just start.
Let's just start.
Oh, God, look at all these goozies on my arm.
Welcome to Smartless.
Guess what I just finished watching moments ago.
A pizza pocket heat up in my arm.
the microwave.
Oh, wait.
Now, let me try.
Yeah.
I wish.
Something with Scotty.
I don't have it yet.
Your zipper on your pants
not be able to close.
Oh, wait, I know what it is.
It's the top button on your trousers
flying across the room and breaking a light bulb.
No, I just watched the first,
literally 10 minutes ago,
finished watching DTF St. Louis,
the first episode.
Oh.
Let me tell you, it is so good.
It is right up my alley.
And Jay, another incredible character by you.
Oh, thank you.
Like really, like so different.
Really quick question.
Did you say it's a ride up your alley?
It's a ride up your alley.
It's right up your alley. It's right up your alley.
He's been saying it wrong for years, Will.
Don't stop him now.
No, it's right up my alley.
The way it's shot and, of course, performed, you're brilliant.
It's so good, Jay.
You're so good in it.
Rider director.
I mean, that's the shot of the swing, that's all I'll say.
Yeah, yeah.
I mean, that's so smart.
It's so cool.
It gets real, real, real, real, real, real crazy.
Yeah, and the ending of the first episode, wow.
It's really good.
Thank you for watching that, you sweet, man.
It's so good.
You're so good.
Do you, I don't know if I've ever admitted this on this show before,
but speaking of saying things wrong for years.
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
And this is, I'll attribute this to not reading a lot.
You know, I'm allergic to books, and I'm not proud of that.
Yeah.
Because I feel if I had I seen this written, I wouldn't have,
made the mistake all these years, but I've always thought that when you say the phrase,
I'm just trying to make ends meet.
I thought that was a phrase that one would say when they're saying, listen, I'm just trying
to get by with just the bare minimum.
I'm not being greedy.
I'm not entitled.
I'm just trying to make ends meet.
Meaning, I'm just looking for the part of the cow that doesn't cost a lot.
I just need sustenance.
I need some food.
I'm looking for ends meat, like M-E-A-T, the end of the cow, the ass,
which is not going to cost you a lot.
This is what my stupid head thought until I'm 57.
And this was probably a couple years ago.
I was 55 until I realized that it is ends of, you know, strings or whatever,
creating a circle.
You want these ends to meet and create a whole thing.
which can mean something similar to.
I'm just trying to make it all come together for myself.
You're trying to make, well, you're trying to, you're trying to be able to afford stuff.
You're trying to make ends meet, you're trying to do stuff within your budget.
Yeah, it wasn't a proud moment for me, but I'm not beyond admitting my flaws.
I'm just trying to think of like the gotcha headlines and the various social media stuff about this.
Oh, no, this will be cut.
No, this is just for you, me, and your guest, well.
We can't cut this.
What kind of cut is that at the end of the cow that you're talking about?
You're talking about your flank steak?
Well, the flank is, it's often called the flank, where the end.
That's not the end.
Wait, but you know that, like, I love, you know that.
Remember, I love, like, sayings and their originate origination, what is I called?
You stupid ass.
Where they originated from.
This is a tough day for me.
Go ahead.
And where they originated from, you know what I mean?
And so remember I did the saved by the bell,
I told you guys about saying by the bell.
You did an episode or an arc?
No, no, where that saying comes from.
Oh.
Remember the guy, people used to get buried.
Remember I told you?
They used to get buried alive.
And they didn't know it at the time because people were unconscious.
They just thought they were dead.
So they'd bury them in these coffins.
Then they dig them back up to reuse the coffins.
And they saw these scratch marks.
So they're like, oh my God, we've been burying people alive.
So they bury people alive.
They tie a string to their toe.
They put it through their.
ground and tie it to a bell
and you're saved by the bell if the bell
goes off. And the person who had to sit there
and wait to see if the bell went off,
worked with the graveyard shift. Wow.
Okay, and this is what you thought
saved by the bell was for years. No, that is
what it is. It's not. It's a boxing thing.
Well, evidently it originated with this, J.B.
That's right. Really? Really? Yes, that's
I'm telling you. Wait, so hang on.
So, Will, you're taking, that's news to you
and you're going with Sean? That's news
to me. I do vaguely remember Sean mentioned
this before.
Yeah.
Well, that doesn't make it true.
He's just repeating insanity.
I mean, I'm sure people can just look it up as they're listening to this right now.
I don't know why we would.
That's where it comes from.
We're going to have our fact checkers get on that while we're, while we're, we've got fact checkers now?
Yeah, yeah.
So let's have to do that.
Will, go ahead, introduce your guest and let's get on with that.
Oh, shoot.
Jason.
This is a little runner that I've been having trying to get Will panicked while he's.
Did I ever get?
get panicked about it?
No, I don't think it worked.
It's my guest and I'm so excited.
And Willie, I think you're going to be excited too.
I think I remember, I think it was you telling me
that you're just a kooky fan for this fella
and I don't blame you because I am too.
Gentlemen, I'm not going to care.
No, no.
Great, let's start.
Let's start.
It's going to be a great hour for you, Sean.
No, you will.
Everybody freaks on this guy for very good reason.
Have you searched for the answer to the age-old question?
What should I do after pursuing rock stardom and being a lawyer?
Well, our guest this week has the answer.
You become one of the finest actors on the planet.
You go out there, you work with the best directors in the world,
you turn in some of the most powerful and moving performances ever,
and then you grab yourself an arm full of awards,
including the little gold guy named Oscar.
He's done three careers worth of work already in his 30 years of performing,
and it's been theater and film and television,
but one of those television projects is now a film,
and he's here to talk to us about that.
Gentlemen, please welcome Tommy Shelby himself,
Mr. Killian Murphy.
Oh, my God.
Yeah, here with us today.
How good.
Oh, Killian.
How cool.
So nice to meet you.
Hey, man.
Nice to meet you.
That was a lovely introduction.
Thank you.
Right, I worked on it for minutes.
What time is it for you today now?
It's like nearly 6pm in London.
Oh, all right.
Now, if you're like me, you're about an hour away from sleep.
Are you in comfy socks?
Are you getting ready to get horizontal?
Or are you about to start your night?
I do start thinking about bed from, yeah, about half past five.
That is true.
So we're keeping you up right now.
No, I mean, I'm just thinking about it.
Yeah.
But I will be approaching.
I'll be in bed by like half nine.
Right?
You're good.
We're all in the same.
It's so nice.
Yeah, I think the four of us are very good at relaxing and taking it easy.
Now, is that because we're of a certain age or is it because we've all really been good at getting after it?
And we're kind of done with that.
Yeah.
Right?
I did it.
And now I want to enjoy the relaxation of wisdom and a.
I don't, I mean, what do you guys think?
What's your...
Well, I'm 100% I agree with Jason, although I was going to ask you, Killian, is like the...
I'm doing theater right now, and I know you've done a lot of theater, and it's like,
all of a sudden you have to retrain your brain to have the most energy at 8 p.m.
Yeah, yeah.
You know, and it's like, of the whole day, you have to have most of your energy at 8 p.m.
And boy, it's rough.
Are you going on stage tonight?
And tomorrow, my quote-unquote week starts Wednesdays.
And he's doing a one-man show, Killing.
And I think you've done one of those, haven't you?
I certainly have.
Yeah, wow.
Good man.
It's a lot.
That's like the fucking Everest of acting.
That's what I call.
It's very right.
Did you ever have, well, Shani, I haven't asked you.
I'll ask you both at the same time.
Has there been a wipeout yet?
Like a total, like, that's my fear.
Like, there's no net.
There's no actor you can find the eyes of.
and sort of communicate silently.
I have no idea what I'm supposed to say next.
Throw me a line.
Yeah, my line the other night was,
he tells me, the line is he tells me
two kids came forward to confess to it.
It was an accident, that's the line.
And three or four shows ago, literally on stage,
he tells,
oh no.
He's just a panic.
It's just unbelievable.
I mean, you feel like it's 20 minutes long
And I go, teenagers brand their car into them, killed them.
And then I just started.
By the way, I'm sure the audience probably did not know this.
No, I know.
And for you, it seemed like interminable.
Like, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But isn't the line you have forgotten linked to the line that follows it?
Yes, of course.
And so you can't just improvise the line you can't remember
because that doesn't shine any light on the next thing you're supposed to say.
But you do know the kind of the context.
You just kind of forget the word order.
so then you paraphrase until you get back on the train.
Yeah, you get back on.
So you got right back on and it was all right.
Yeah, yeah, it was fine.
Killian, any nightmare like that?
Yeah.
You know the way, when you're doing theater,
it's like you got like the left-hand side and the right-hand,
so you've got the sort of stage-manager side of your brain
and you've got the acting side of your brain, right?
So you've got the stage-manager side going, right,
you drop the prop back there,
so you've got to go back and pick up the prop while you're saying the lines.
That's right.
And they're acting similar.
They're running parallel.
So you've got this kind of management in your head going,
well, you've got to fix this,
and then the other side is talking.
So I did probably, but I was, it was like,
I quite liked not having to rely on the, you know,
the terrified eyes across the stage to some other actor,
like saying, can you pick up the fucking knife that was not supposed to.
So I quite enjoyed it.
But what I did find, and I don't know about you, Sean,
I could not sleep after it.
I could not go to sleep.
It's been rough.
Really?
Yeah.
Just wired.
Yeah. Absolutely. It was like being thrown out of a helicopter. I could not sleep.
How are you about the folks coming backstage and wanting to congratulate you and talk a little bit?
Like, are you, I would imagine that thing. I'm obsessed with this.
I know. Because I don't want to be fucking bothered for the most part at any point in the day.
This will keep you from doing Broadway. This very thing will keep you from doing Broadway.
I'm with you though, Jay. I'm with you. But I just feel like I would feel, I would feel burdened to,
to make the person feel comfortable.
Right.
Backstage.
And I would just feel their awkwardness,
and I would feel like I need to host them now.
And I need to, just because I don't want people to feel uncomfortable.
So, like, I'm still working.
I'm still on.
And do you feel that either one of you guys with that moment, Killian?
Yeah.
And I would be, I think when I was younger,
I would always be up for the, like, come back to the dress.
I mean, we'll have a drink, and we'll go out.
But then as I got older, I just couldn't fake it, I think, any long.
But equally, I couldn't sleep.
So I didn't know what to do.
Like, I didn't go for a long walk, have a bath.
Because the adrenaline, you mean still?
Yeah, and then go to the pub.
I didn't want to go to the pub.
Sit alone, drinking, not a good idea.
So what do you, like, what do you do?
I don't know what to do.
Yeah.
Well, can I ask you?
This is another thing I'm fascinated with.
And guys, plug yours, you've heard me twat on about this before.
But is it the same practice overseas there that it is apparently in New York where if you are famous, even pseudo famous, you are obligated to go backstage and pay your respects and say hi.
Even if the actor, even if you don't know the actor, any of the actors, and they don't know that you're there.
What I've heard is that it's very rude to just watch the show and leave
if you're of any sort of notoriety.
Is that the same thing over there?
Do you guys go back?
Sometimes.
My other half makes me go back.
So you prefer not to, but you recognize that there is a practice.
There is a tradition, there's an obligation.
There is, yeah.
Yeah, there's like a little pressure.
Like if they know you're in the audience because the stage manager comes up and says,
they would love to say hi or if you would like to
then you kind of have to
then you do that that's just that's just courteous
but if you don't know the person
and they haven't made that connection
I think you're well within your right to just sort of
Yeah I mean I've had people come that don't that don't come back
I don't pick I don't think anything about it
Even if they they're not in house seats or anything like that
So there's no way for them to assume that you know that they're there
I went to see Sean in previews
I went to see Sean in previews that I didn't tell them and I just left
I didn't even go and say I don't
Oh it wasn't until we all went together that I went back
state. Not true, Sean. Not true.
So, Killian, it's the same
thing overseas, as far as
the practice, the tradition? Yeah, I mean, I can't.
People, people
do... I remember once I was
in, I was doing a show in New York and I had a night
off like you have, Sean, and
at the time John Hurt was doing
Crapslas tape, and I went
to see the play and it was unbelievable
and it was, you know, it was John Hurt.
And then stage manager came up and said,
would you like to go back and meet Mr. Hurt?
And I went, I was doing
show at the same time and I thought, would I like
John Hurt came back to see me?
No, I wasn't comparing myself to John Hurt, I was, and I went,
and I went, and I went, I just leave him. So I just left.
And then afterwards I went, you fucking idiot.
Why didn't you not go back and meet John Hurt?
He's like one of my acting heroes.
But I didn't, because I felt he might be a little tired.
And it's like, you're famous, I'm famous,
so I thought I'd come back and say, hi, that's the thing
that sort of cringes me out about it.
But I hear that it's actually the opposite,
that it's, it's, you should.
Let's bring it up more often, Jay.
Yeah.
Wait, I want to hear about Fillion's musical career.
I didn't know this about you.
Can you expand on that a little bit?
Yeah.
Well, it seems to be, excuse me, it seems to be quite common, doesn't it?
That there's a lot of frustrated musicians in acting.
I've counted lots of them.
Yeah.
And, yeah, it's initially what I'm sure does probably some of you guys are among them,
but that's all I wanted to do from the very beginning was play music.
And when I saw you, Jason, was at the radio head show.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then obviously it didn't work out.
So I kind of moved into theatre, I think,
for to try and get that live experience, you know,
that connection with an audience that you get when you play music.
And then that just became the main thing.
But it was always music, yeah.
And I'm still obsessed with it.
Are you?
My first love of you.
I didn't know that what, are you in a band?
I'm sorry, forgive me.
No, I mean, you should.
Why would you?
He was with his brother.
And is it true?
Is this a story?
This is Wikipedia facts.
So forgive our rigorous journalism skills.
But you guys were, you guys had a band together.
And then there was a record label that wanted you to sign.
But you were like,
This smells like maybe an overreach, and so let's not sign,
and then things kind of transitioned into theater,
and that became your passion?
Was that kind of the way it went?
More or less, yeah, more or less.
Like, my brother was still, he was playing keys in the man,
and he was only 16 or something when we were off of the record deal.
So my parents said, absolutely verboten, you're not, like, ruining your life.
You, they said to me, I can ruin my life, but then we just didn't.
But Patty, we were going to protect.
Yeah. So we, it just all kind of fell apart.
Yeah.
And then I'd never been to the theatre before that.
And then after that I saw a play in Cork City where I'm from, which was like...
Pluckler Orange?
Exactly, yeah.
And it was a promenade version of that play.
And absolutely, absolutely like, I just, it was the greatest thing I'd ever seen.
Had you seen the film before that?
Not at that. It was banned in Ireland.
Oh, really?
It was banned in Ireland.
The first time I saw it was I bought a VHS copy of it in Canada.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's wild.
My grandpa's from Dingell.
We love it in Canada.
We love it.
My grandfather's from Dingell.
My grandmother is from County Kerry.
Yeah.
Oh, man.
I mean, I spent a lot of time in Dingle and around the West of the world.
It's beautiful, right?
Shawnee, have you been over there?
Yeah.
Just once.
It's just
to Ding, I mean to Ireland
a couple times, but to Dingle just once,
I still have a, I still, we have still have cousins,
like distant cousins, I think that still live there.
But yeah, it's really pretty old.
I still have a sweatshirt that says, I got this.
Dingleberry.
So the first
time you really experienced
the theaters when you saw Clockwork Orange on stage,
yeah, is that what your, is that
what your testimony is?
Do we have your answer, right?
Yeah.
Well, how did that, how did that moment go?
Because your parents are both educators, yes?
Correct, yeah.
And so this conversation of, hey, I've got good news and even better news.
I'm stopping my pursuit of rock and roll and I'm going into theater.
Was that, were they, were they buoyed?
by that or were they like, no, Killian,
were they all right with it?
Like, I was, you mentioned I had a very short flirtation with like law.
I did like a year of a law degree and I failed like abysmally.
And then I tried to get the repeats and then I got the repeats and then I got a part of the play.
So I think by that stage, Jade kind of got like, whatever.
Just he's going to do, he's going to do his thing.
You know, I was 20 then.
So that's when you're meant to make mistakes, isn't it?
Of course.
And declare, I'm not really sure, but I'm following some instincts, and those are going to change.
Listen, Killing, I'm continuing making mistakes and I'm 55.
Yes, you're all the same.
Right.
I am, as I said the other day, I'm firmly in the student section in life.
I've finally come to that realization that I'm like, it's okay.
Well, your tan and the ceiling fan looks like you're doing all right right now.
It is. I know it's really going.
I'm sorry about that.
I had to walk around and find the best place to get internet.
I'm not kidding.
Checking out what had the best.
It's right here with the fanbombo.
You've got a monkey on a wheel.
You know, just keeping the Wi-Fi going.
But I'm curious about you deciding to try to get a law degree, like that decision.
And then while you're doing that, thinking the whole time, wait a second, I'd rather be doing theater.
Like, I've been affected by this.
I've got this thought.
Is that kind of, how did that all kind of transcend?
inspire.
I think I just had that natural inclination to perform, which I'm sure you guys are familiar
with, you know, just from the very early age.
I'm quite a shy person, but I really enjoy getting up on a stage.
I hate getting up on stages myself, but I love getting up on stage as someone else
or playing music.
Isn't that a weird thing where, you know, I think all four of us are, you know, proudly private
people.
we don't we're not we're not shy per se because of what we do but like isn't it isn't it an interesting
thing where we'll sit there in front of the camera and be exposed to millions and millions of people
you know wanting uh hoping in a perfect world millions of people are going to watch what i am doing
yet we we sort of shy away from being um you know the center of attention uh often when we when we go
out or even when we go out to promote that thing that we want people to see we're sort of like
I mean I'll speak for myself it's just like I got to go out and talk about it over here and over
there and kind of light my hair on fire it is sort of the the two things are kind of at odds with
one another the one's controlled and one isn't yeah that's a very good point that's true that's true
what's your what's your what's your favorite way uh Killian to interact with fans like when is it when is it
comfortable for you.
I think I know what my answer would be.
Well, tell me yours, because tell me yours.
I feel if it's one-on-one and them, us talking is not going to cause a larger sort of spectacle
and cause a scene.
Like I don't want to embarrass myself, my kids, them, you know, create a, so like in an elevator.
If it's just me and one person and, you know,
And we can have a little conversation as opposed to, oh, take a picture here and then people walking by look at what's going on here.
Oh, maybe I should get a picture too.
Oh, yeah, I recognize that person.
And then it becomes a thing.
And then, I don't know.
I like sort of the one-on-one stuff.
What about you?
I'm the same, yeah.
Yeah.
I love a chat.
I love a real chat and someone has really enjoyed something you've done.
Right.
Like, particularly, like, you know, we've all been in shows that have run a long time and people love.
the people are very invested in characters, right?
Sure.
And so you have to acknowledge that investment
and that they've spent that much time with your characters.
And I love those conversations, you know?
I don't like when stuff gets like fetishized.
He's going to the shop to buy milk, my God.
He's just like us.
Right.
But I love a conversation.
And we will be right back.
And now back to the show.
Are you able at times to have the same kind of experience with your characters that some of your fans might?
In other words, are you able to watch what you do and enjoy it from an audience point of view?
Or can you not get the separation from your experience inside the character?
That's a great question
And I'd love to hear what you guys think about it
Well start with
Do you watch your own stuff
Or are you an actor that
Because I know both
Both very very good actors
That watch themselves and learn from that
And then others that they can't
And they won't
Well it's different jobs sometimes
Like this Peeky Blinders film
Like we had the premiere last night
In Birmingham
I just watched it two nights ago
It's incredible
Incredible
I can't wait
It was very cool
and what I was producer on that
so I've seen the thing like 500 times
so you know
I like it was a very
different kind of experience
watching it too
you know when you just turn up and as an actor for hire
and you do your work and then you see it
and some stuff I've never seen it all
and some stuff I'm immensely proud of
but again I mean
I feel like I try to move forward
with everything then it's like
about the next thing
rather than going backwards.
What about you guys?
What's your take on it?
Do any of you sit around watching your work
endlessly?
That's how I wake up every morning.
I can't get out of bed without it.
That's your alarm.
What about on set?
Will you ever watch a little bit of playback?
Even at the beginning of the production,
just to get a sense of how you're coming across,
how they're lighting you,
the lenses, or just to get a feel of the tone of it.
Occasionally, particularly for technical stuff.
You know, like stuff that's technical or like a stunt or whatever.
But I know I would never go back and look at like a big emotional stuff.
But the producing thing has been interesting because it takes the curse off it a little bit.
You know, you look at it and you just go, oh my God, that's how you look.
And then you just go, right.
But it's important for this character to do this and this guy's got to enter here
and she's got to say this and we've got to cut here.
And then it takes a curse off it.
Sure.
Well, you look at it and you look at it through a different lens, obviously, right?
So you just, like this thing that I did last year,
I spend a lot of time having to watch different cuts and stuff
and eventually got to a place where I got over watching myself
and was actually able to watch it really objectively.
Yes.
About, wait, are we telling the best version of the story?
We should go back.
We should tell you, are we telling the best version?
Is this the best thing?
But all these kinds of things, you know.
And it did, as you say, sort of break the curse a little bit.
I was no longer watching my performance.
I was watching a bigger thing.
Yeah.
just sort of being an audience number.
Zero.
I always think I'm slightly better looking than I actually am.
And then I'll watch it.
I'll go, no, then.
No, you're not.
You're not at all, actually.
Turned it off.
Close to being what you thought you looked like.
I know.
Well, Killion, was there, speaking of music and then law and all this,
was there ever a moment where, and thank God you didn't,
But was there ever a moment where you thought, yeah, maybe this acting thing, let's put that in the bin as well.
Let's try career path number four and go into industry X or occupation Y.
Did you ever think about giving up on doing this?
No, really. After a period, you kind of like, you burnt your bridges, I think.
And there's nothing else available really.
And during the fallow periods, obviously, get really cranky.
what the fuck is it
but and I don't like I'm not a writer
I'm definitely not a writer and
so I didn't have that
but I would go and play music in the kind of
fallow bits or just you know
just go and just watch movies and read books but
it is I didn't know I never
got to the stage where I thought
ah fuck this but I did
whenever the stuff started to get kind of dry up in film or television
I was very lucky to have a friend of mine
called Enda Walsh who I made a little
awful lot of theater with and we did some really great plays he gave me my first ever play part in a
play after i saw clock garange when i was like 19 to 20 and so i continued to work with him making like
new plays throughout my 30s and 40s and that kind of kept me sane i think you know when this stuff
kind of just people aren't calling you know yeah wow that's great that's great so you established like
So long ago, this collaboration,
and you've managed to sort of keep it going for all these years.
Yeah, I haven't done a play in a while now
because it's kind of become a little terrifying to me.
Honestly, I'm a little scared of.
Is it because you're worried about Jason Bateman coming backstage
and saying, hi, for the show?
Is that what's keeping you away?
Killian, it's me again.
I've come back for one more night.
I'm just outside.
I want every theater to put up Jason's picture backstage
do not let this guy back here.
Super eager will not leave.
So you start going to try to do it
and they're like, no, no, we're good.
It's the main reason I did this podcast
so that we could talk about it, actually.
Send up the warning.
Is there something that you have...
Is there some sort of advice
that you have...
you've gained with your experience now?
That you wish you could go back and tell that dude
back then that...
Don't worry about the fallow periods.
It's going to be, is there something that you wish you would have known then
that would have made those ups and those downs a bit more tolerable?
Yeah.
This is a great question.
I mean, aside from, don't worry, you're going to win an Oscar one day.
Hang in there.
Yeah.
You know?
Yeah, that would definitely lighten the mood.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I think it's that thing about overthinking stuff, you know, overthinking it,
over-intellectualizing everything.
and not sticking to your instinct, I think, is the key thing for artists.
I know, but what is that, I know, but what is that healthy balance?
Because I've always heard that with everything in life, with all of us.
I think we've all heard somebody say as, ah, you're overthinking it.
But, like, isn't, how do you know what the difference is between overthinking and just simply,
you're just using the intelligence that you've been working on?
You know, it's like, we work.
hard to be smart, or at least we think that we're smart.
And so how do you know when to pull back on that?
I just don't know.
Well, what's your guys approach to like prep then, for example?
Because sometimes I would get so over, it would just take up everything and everything
we're all consuming.
But then the whole point when you get into a scene is that you have to be completely
free of all that.
Yeah, no idea.
So it's kind of counterintuitive or counterproductive to have a lot of that prep sometimes.
but yet you think your duty is to do all of that.
So what, what, how, how, what have you arrived?
It's shifted for me.
I was, I was different from Jason because I was blown away that,
and maybe you do this too will.
Do, do this too will.
It's like I make sure I'm off book completely from the first time I step on set
or walk out on the rehearsal room or whatever it is.
Because if I, if I'm having my book in my hand or whatever,
I just can't be free, like you're saying, Kalyan, to explore and bring.
where Jason has said in the past, where you don't make choices,
you just literally memorize the words and then you work on it in rehearsal.
But I don't even memorize the words because my part in the term process,
when I memorize has a lot to do with my imagination of kind of how that's going to kind of go.
And I don't like to decide or start to approach a decision of how I'm going to do something
until I see and understand what the other actors are going to be doing.
and what the director is looking for
and how the scene is blocked
and where camera's going to be
and all this stuff.
Because if I predetermined
how I'm going to do something
and what my faces are going to look like
and the wires are going to work
with what the other people are doing.
You've got that book of faces.
I know you've got that book of polarize.
I've got those memorized.
I started doing, I started memorizing
in really monotone ways.
It's truly, I started memorizing
monotone way and recording myself.
This is true.
And with a very monotone voice
so that I had zero inflection and crossing out all stage direction.
And just taking all of that away.
And I did get into a situation I was working on this thing.
And I got there and they're like,
now you've got to go and get the thing on the other side of the room.
I'm like, oh, do I?
I didn't even know that I had it.
You know, but because I, but actually it was very helpful
because it just happened very organically
and I hadn't thought about that.
And so it's really shifted as I've gotten older
how I look at it
and my preparation is so much different
now than it was.
And also, J.B., I think about, like,
when we used to do
Arrested Development, for instance,
it was much more...
Sean, it's a TV show.
Yeah, it's a TV show.
It used to be a band.
We got sued by them.
I think for...
I think for when you're...
I used to think about it sort of prepping
to do comedy, especially,
because it was so quick and it would happen
so that it didn't serve,
me certainly and I know that you were similar in this way J.B.
Because we did a lot of scenes together.
That it was, you just kept it.
It was all kind of just at the surface until you got there.
Right, because that puts, that increases my odds of reacting to you
like the audience is experiencing it.
Yeah, it's so much about rhythm and comedy in that way.
Rhythm is the big thing, I think.
The meaning can come after the rhythm or I guess for you guys,
like if the comedy or the gag or the bit,
that comes out.
But like if you get into a rhythm in a scene,
and I guess if you have a predetermined rhythm,
then how are you going to lock in with anyone else?
You can't, you can't, and you can't,
you need to stay nimble to allow for shit to happen.
But I do think it's different for a theater
because I would be the same as you, Sean,
like with a theater piece,
I would be completely off book when I get to rehearsed.
But you also have, and here's the difference.
You also have a theater.
By the time you get there,
and you're in rehearsal,
I mean, Sean, I know you, for instance, in this,
and also for Good Night Oscar.
What a show!
That you were completely off book.
Yeah, I had to you.
But then you get into previews,
and now you've got a couple weeks of previews.
And it changes.
And it changes, and that starts to eat away
at all your predeterminate stuff that you have.
But you don't have that luxury
when you're making a film or making a show.
It's, it's the performance is that day.
And that's it.
Yeah, it's funny. You know, it's funny. There is this one line where I reference a very famous musical in this current show. And one of the producers of this famous musical came to the show and didn't like that we mentioned his musical that he produced. So it's a 75-minute monologue. It's just me. And so we had to change the one word to another musical. And so from the time you started, all I thought about from the time the curtain opened was that one word I had to change.
it right now.
And I was like, oh, shit.
From the time you started.
Yeah.
I was like, thanks a lot, dude.
All right.
Killing, 28 days later.
That was,
first film?
No.
No, I've done a few films in Ireland,
kind of small independent films in Ireland.
This is the one that,
what a film.
Yeah.
Put you on a lot.
of a lot of radars.
I guess so, yeah.
Yeah, and did it feel like, okay, I've got a little bit of wind at my back now,
and this might work out?
Yes?
Yeah, yeah, I think so.
At that stage, the film, like, we never expected the film to do well,
and it did well.
But you did have Danny Boyle.
I mean, you knew your odds were good, right?
They were good.
They were, because he's a master.
And I had like his posters of his films on my wall
and my bedroom growing up, you know,
before I ever became an actor,
because they were just so cool, like trainsprouting and shallow grave.
I love trains.
And I mean, it's a masterpiece.
But the thing about it was that zombie genre was,
wasn't very cool at the time or it wasn't really like,
there hadn't been a kind of a zombie thing.
Right.
And even though this is technically like an infection,
they're not undead.
But anyway, at that time that we shot it,
like it was the summer of 2001,
and then obviously like 9-11 happened.
But before that, SARS had happened.
And then obviously all those years later,
like COVID happened,
and it became this kind of meme.
It's a very prescient writing, very good writing.
Yeah.
And people went nuts for it, the original movie.
So, yeah, it was a great,
It's the start.
But I went through the ringer for that movie.
Danny, I had like five or six auditions for that to get the parks.
It done very little at the time.
I kind of knew it was a real substantial script.
Alex Garland wrote the script and Danny directed him.
Great writer.
Yeah.
He was such a great writer and an amazing director.
Amazing director.
What was the moment from your last audition?
When did you find out that you got it after going through all this auditions and being like, Jesus Christ?
You remember that moment?
You remember where you were?
I do actually.
I was in a, I was in Stansted Airport in the queue
to get a Ryanair flight back to Dublin.
And Danny called me.
I had to do one of those like unbelievably contained celebrations.
Like drop my bag and sit down and kind of, but yeah, it was massive for me.
That movie.
It's fucking 23 years ago or something.
Wow.
Now, he talks often, doesn't he, about energy over perfection?
Do I have that right?
His sort of his MO on set.
Can you explain what he might mean by that?
What his direction, his environment is like, what that set is like, what his style is like?
Sounds about it right.
He's incredible energy and passion for it.
Like he never stops moving.
He never stops.
like he's on every single element of the set
and it's constant ideas,
constant, he's constantly pushing, you know,
and really pushing the actors
and pushing every department.
And I absolutely love that at that age.
I don't think I'd been in, you know,
working with someone who was so coherent
in their vision for the film, if you know what I mean.
Yeah, sure, just full enthusiasm and just knows all four corners of what this scene's supposed to do and how it's supposed to be done.
Yeah. And it's infectious. And every time you think, oh, that was pretty good. Like, you know, you're off again.
And we shot that on domestic cameras, like these little, do you remember in the early 2000s?
Everyone had these little cameras with, like, cards in them and stuff.
So they're all like stuff you could buy.
Like camcorders almost. Yeah.
Yeah. They were slightly more advanced. I can't remember what, at the first.
format is.
But anyway, it was just one of those movies that kind of clicked, you know.
Yeah.
A style that I would imagine is, is it wildly different than, you know, what an incredible
collaboration you've had with Christopher Nolan?
Yeah, I was going to get to it.
Incredible.
That from what I, from what I understand, what I've heard is a more exacting and and, and
contained and deliberate approach to the execution, yes or no?
And to the extent you're comfortable talking about it,
because I would assume that environments on sets,
well, not assume, I know, they're often private,
individual environments that are weird to redescribe.
But it just strikes me having, not many actors get to work with the same director,
six different projects.
I'd imagine you guys have a bit of a short.
shorthand and a real comfort in each other's style.
Oh, yeah.
I mean, I've learned so much from Chris.
He's completely kind of shaped my whole career.
I mean, it's very clear, like working over 20 years.
But he's absolutely remarkable.
He is incredibly rigorous, incredibly precise.
But within that, there's fantastic freedom.
Yeah.
You know, there's only one camera and there's Chris,
and he's got this tiny little monitor.
and he has, like, puts back to the...
Never two cameras.
Rarely unless there's a big set piece, you know?
But he has this tiny little thing, again, from, like, the 90s
that he watches a shitty little playback from the thing.
But he rarely is watching it because he's right beside the camera watching you.
And you'll never leave it.
He'll never leave a scene unless he feels like, you know,
you're happy and he's happy.
And it's...
I can't really explain how wonderful it is,
how focused is, how fast it is, but yet it never feels fast.
Like, we shot Oppenheimer in 59 days or something like that.
Wow.
With all that scope.
I know.
It's amazing.
So do you think that that speed or that efficiency, it just comes as a result of him
really being precise about knowing what he wants, what he needs, he's properly prepared,
and he doesn't hang around longer than he's gotten what he wants for that particular shot,
and off we go?
Exactly.
I mean, he's written the thing
and he knows every single frame
he's storyboarded it all in his head
So it's, and the thing about Nolan movies is
If, when they used to be DVDs, there was never any extras
Because he shoots the script
This script is the script
There's no deleted scenes, there's no extra
It's the script
And he finishes every movie
Like ahead of schedule on the budget
Yeah, do you feel
Having him, yeah, it's pretty remarkable
Having him right next to camera
And obviously you guys
because you've worked so much together, there is a comfort there.
Do you get a comfort of having,
do you feel that comfort of having him right there
next to camera, close to you?
Yeah.
There's no such thing as video village or like,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's like when I stand next to you, Will.
Yeah.
You just comfort.
You can see it.
No, we're talking about comfort.
But I mean, so then I'm going to ask you,
so you feel that and you might, that's, yeah,
it's evident in your work that you do with him.
And so I wonder if when you go and you do work with other directors,
do you ever feel that like sort of sense of not detachment,
but sometimes if it is further, they are further away
or they are at Video Village and you don't have that sort of that proximity,
that relationship that's so close, do you feel the difference sometimes?
And I don't mean this to disparage other directors clearly.
Sure, no, I understand.
No, I think it's like what we were discussing earlier.
You know, over time, I think it's our duty to be really,
really, really flexible, isn't it?
Because if you come on one set with us,
and this is the only way I will work.
Some directors love to rehearse.
Some directors don't love to rehearse.
Some directors love, have everybody look at the monitor
and chat and others, you know, don't do that.
So you have to kind of bend to their approach, I find.
And I love doing that.
Like, you know, I don't particularly love rehearsing on film,
but if there's a director that insists on it,
I'll go for it, you know?
because it's their vision and I'm just there to serve the vision.
So I kind of like that at the adventure of it.
And I'm sure you guys are all the same.
You know, it's like, it's always like a new circuses.
And every time you get a new job, it's like this new circus and what's it going to involve?
And what are, you know, so I like that.
For sure.
We'll be right back.
And back to the show.
How do you like affecting the health of that?
circus, the harmony of that environment, depending on your level of influence on that set.
Like, you know, just even the Nolan films, for example, there are some where you're a part of an
ensemble and then like Oppenheimer, you're the lead and you're, you're, you're, you can, you can,
you can affect the environment.
Pecky blinders, you know, again, sort of the, the captain and also in a, in a producer,
position as well. Do you enjoy that sort of leadership position or do you like to disappear
and just be sort of part of the team and be like a soldier? I think it's a bit of both really, isn't
that? Because it's funny you say soldier because the whole like the whole film set is based
off like the old military kind of setup, isn't it? Like, you're your director and your first AD
and your second AD and your third AD and you know, everyone's got number one in the college,
you're number two in the call. You know, it's it has to work. And it has to work.
like that and you know
and everything comes from the top I think
you know the atmosphere and the
ambiance and the vibe and the energy
always is percolates down
from the leaders like the producers
and the director and the lead actors down
to how everyone so I think
it's always nice to
I love to have a set where people are having a bit of fun
and a bit of crack and crack
in the Irish vernacular
yeah yeah yeah yeah
we were with you we were with you
okay I could
Oh, boy.
Killian Murphy loves crack.
We've got our, yep.
Killion, how do you speak about healthy?
How do you stay so fit?
You're always like, you're, I know you're younger than us, but.
I think it's crack.
Is it not?
He just told us.
Because you have kids too, right?
You're constantly working.
You're constantly on the go.
But you're in, like, incredible shape.
Will looks pretty good.
He does.
Oh, thanks, man.
That's bronzer.
A lot of that's bronze.
Yeah, it is.
I just sprayed it on.
No, I think all of you guys are very well maintained.
I think it's kind of part of the job, isn't it?
Unfortunately, or fortunately, I don't know.
Well, there's another part of that Wikipedia, incredible hints I got.
There was, is it true that you, to avoid mad cow disease, you went vegetarian.
Then you started eating, then you started eating meat to bulk up for Piki Blind.
and then you stopped eating and you're back to vegetarian for,
it didn't give me the reason for the return.
But do they have it right so far?
That's more or less accurate.
I met my wife when I was 20 and she's been a vegetarian all the life.
So I was kind of became a vegetarian then.
And then I did kind of, so it was more out of convenience than of any real sort of, you know,
opposition to it.
But now I do do it because I don't really want to eat animals.
And if you were to, you would make ends meet.
Thank you, Will.
And that's our episode, everybody.
Thank you for joining us.
Wonderful book.
We have made the two pieces of string connect at the bottom.
No, but you know, that whole bulking up thing,
I know I'm all over the place,
but I saw this documentary once
because I went vegetarian for a year,
to try to lower my cholesterol,
and it only dropped one point
after 12 months of eating nothing but like,
you know, sticks and berries, yeah.
Wasn't that long ago.
But I watched this documentary
when I was doing it,
and they made a point that you don't need meat to bulk up
because they made a point that, like,
gorillas are vegetarians,
rhinoceros,
girat, like, these huge animals,
all they eat are leaves.
Yeah, you're absolutely right there.
I do that.
The update is that I am now, like, I've always been pescatarian and I don't eat any meat.
So that's the Wikipedia update.
So this fish?
We'll add that in there today.
Thanks.
You say you do do the fish?
I do do the fish, yes.
Right, right.
And you're entirely right.
It's very possible if you need to do that to do it through plant protein, of course.
I don't know.
I was just being an idiot back then.
I'm still an idiot.
All right, let's talk to me about Peaky Blinders.
Now, just how long did you have been doing, how long did you, sorry, Jay,
how long did you do Peaky Blinders before,
how long have been living in the world of Peaky Blinders?
So we did the show on and off for, since two, two, we shot the first season in the end of 2012.
So on and off.
Wow, 14 years.
So which I worked out was like a quarter of my life.
Yeah.
And how have you, I'm sure.
you have enjoyed because you could have left it earlier.
But you have undoubtedly enjoyed the progression of Tommy
and shaping his growth along with Stephen Knight, yes.
Yes, but I'm curious to know about you guys as well,
because people ask me this stuff and, you know, that old showbiz adage,
like, you know, don't quit a hit.
Like, so when, like, if something is working,
and people, you know, a lot of journalists will say,
oh, it must be, you know, hard going back playing the sink.
It's amazing writing.
Well, if it's incredibly high quality, like what you guys have there,
and the film, my God, took it to even a higher level of production value
and cinematic pleasures, just unbelievably well directed and shot and scored and performed and lit.
I mean, what a film.
But yes, amen.
If you've got a gig in this business,
stick with it.
These people that like quit their series job
because they want to be open
for all the feature opportunities
that they feel might be just around the corner.
It's like, no ding-dong.
You got time for those too.
I love that character of yours.
The guy who talks like this,
who does the thing that did.
I want to be freed up for features.
Like, give me.
Yeah, exactly.
But also, I think the thing that those people forget is that the features people are all watching the show.
Right.
Yeah.
And thinking, of course.
Right.
Wouldn't they be great in my film?
Yeah.
Right, right.
Killing, do you spend a lot of time in the States or are you happy where you are?
I do come over for work.
I've never lived other than for jobs.
For jobs.
So you love Ireland?
Well, I lived in London for a long time for like we lived here for 14.
years. Oh, you live in London now? I'm sorry. No, I'm sorry. Sorry, we're back in Ireland
now for about 10 years, but we did live in London for 14. And then before that, we're kind of like,
you know, wherever work would take me, I guess. Why do you ask, Sean, do you have a B,
Airbnb? Well, no, it'll be nice to have a. You got a rental that you were just pay off
the mortgage, just a cover cost, right? And what can you offer them? Housekeeper comes twice a week?
Did the occupants just take off on you? I just think first and last in a deposit. We're good.
No, because, no, I don't know, I'm always curious because I love it where you are,
and I get, I get the draw to both.
I mean, America is obviously incredible.
Yeah, but we're kind of like itinerant, aren't we?
You just have to follow the work, and that's the nature of it.
Yeah, we're in the circus, as you say.
Yeah, and you kind of, circus.
My friend once called it the Circus of the Unemployable.
I think it was a very good phrase.
That is.
The thing I was going to ask you about
doing multiple seasons,
years of the same character
is,
you know,
how much of you enjoyed having that character grow
with you because of you?
Has Killian grown
through what you've been experimenting with,
with Tommy?
I mean,
I'm sure there's a,
there's a yes to all of this.
So I'm not positive what the question is,
which is a habit of mine.
I know what you mean.
I know I think it's a good question.
And honestly, I don't really have a really good answer, though,
because we've just finished it and it's just coming out.
And I think need a little bit of distance to reflect.
I think it's what my initial kind of response to it
is that it was a massive gift
to be able to tap that vein of writing
and for it to stay that good.
And for it to,
because it was this little show on BBC 2 on a Sunday night
that, you know,
no one had any expectations for it.
I had no promotion or anything like that.
And it was genuinely made by fans on the internet
telling each other to watch it.
Yeah. Yeah.
It just grew and grew one of those kind of beautiful,
a kind of freaks that happened sometimes in our business
where people just love it.
And then the show gets confidence.
Yeah, it's because, I mean, I would think it was because it took such a distinct point of
you.
You weren't sort of pandering to a huge audience.
You know, you were sort of like, we're going to make the show that we really like.
We're going to shoot it the way we want to shoot it.
We're going to put this music in there that we really love.
And hopefully enough people like it to just keep us on the air, but we're not looking to be
some massive hit.
and that type of specificity and commitment
actually yielded a real fervent fan base.
As opposed to sort of trying to retrofit,
trying to go like, we want to make a show
that hits all this audience, and so how can we,
and that's a recipe for disaster.
I wonder, Killing, were there moments during various seasons of the show
and certainly before the film,
were there moments you're like, this is it, this is the last one,
and then it happened again?
Like, did you ever have those where you felt like,
or was it always open-ended, like we're going to do more?
Well, they wouldn't, they were never,
like we only got one series and then we were hoping we'd get recommissioned,
you know, I think we did maybe four and five, one after the other.
I can't really recall.
But he all, like Steve always had it in his head,
so the series begins at the end of World War I,
and he always had it in his head that it would end at the beginning,
sort of the beginning of World War II
and he's achieved that.
So that was such a, like no one had,
like there's lots and lots of,
you know, films about the First World War
and many, many, many films
about the Second World War,
but not so many films or TV shows
that deal with Britain between the wars.
So that's where he said it.
And in Birmingham, which is like the second city
in the UK and
has,
its very own specific and unique history.
And so,
I think because, like you say, it didn't have these ambitions to be this huge show,
but yet because it was so unique that people came to it, I don't know.
I just don't know why.
Yeah, well, if we all knew it made a hit, everything would be a hit.
You are such a classy fellow.
I'm sure you'd be very hesitant to take any credit.
But I would guess that you can take some credit perhaps for,
for the incredibly, beautifully bold move of the music.
Herkos?
The music throughout the show, is that, is that something that, I mean, given your music
background, your current musical taste, I mean, it's just such a, it's such an exciting
sort of juxtaposition and, you know, this modern fucking punk rock throughout something
that is set in, you know, World War I.
is just great.
It was a, that was a bit of a kind of a, I guess, like a big swing at the time.
And Otto Bathurst directed the first three series.
And he put that Nick Cave tune, that Red Right Hand right at the beginning of the,
and it was incredibly anachronistic.
And it shouldn't have worked for some reason, it did.
And then we were kind of off.
And then all these artists threw out it like PJ Harvey and like David Bowie,
Radiohead.
and everybody started, you know, wanting to have their music on the show
and giving us original music.
And it's been kind of remarkable.
It's just an really privilege.
For a music nerd, like me, you know.
Yeah.
What a treat.
All right.
Well, I'm assuming you've answered this question a million times,
but putting Peky Blinders to bed, I will ask you,
are you good, I'm sure you're going to take a big part of him with you.
Do you, do you, are you going to miss him?
Are you going to miss playing that, that character?
It's just been, you just done so much work in that skin.
I guess I suppose I probably will.
Yeah.
I don't think about it.
What do you guys feel about those long-running shows and those characters?
I'm curious to know.
Just turn the page, right?
Yeah.
But do you actually feel, I mean, are you extremely unsentimental
or do you have a great affection for them?
My personal either limits or strategy or style or whatever is to find that character inside of me.
You know, it's usually way over on one side or the other of what my goalposts are, you know, the limits of who I am.
So that person's always inside of me.
So I'll always carry that character with me a bit.
I feel like if it's outside my goalpost, then I get into acting.
So I got to find, you know, there would there would.
be a
version of him
inside me somewhere.
What about you two fellows?
Yeah, I'm
proud and excited that
the fans love the character I played
for so many years.
But for me personally, yeah, like Jason
just said, ready to move
on after that. Yeah.
I'm not sentimental in that way.
Yeah. Yeah, neither am I, yeah.
You're happy to say kind of goodbye,
nice knowing you next.
Yeah. I think so. Yeah, and very
proud of it and like you say like really proud that it had such an impact and that the people
invested so much but yeah yeah it have to have a forward momentum it's more for me usually it's the
people I've worked with doing it that it's really tragic that we have to get used to saying goodbye
to that's an odd muscle that we all unfortunately have to have to have to strengthen is
saying goodbye to these families that we're constantly creating on sets that's the strange thing
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
You know, when you run into someone,
I was just thinking about you run into people
that you worked with on something really intensely
and you see them like at a restaurant or out of the street
or at something else, you know,
and I don't even just mean actors like anybody
who's part of the filmmaking process,
a production designer or whomever,
and you see them, you're like, and you go, hey,
and you've got this, you've got this like really intense
part of your life where you had this real
where you were both doing this creative endeavor.
You're like, hey,
But you've always got that, you know what I mean?
And your family has no idea who these people are.
And you've spent more time with them in the last few years than you have your actual family.
And they've never met them.
And they bring you such joy in that moment when you see them.
Yeah, yeah.
Yes, and then it's instant there's no like getting to know you again.
It's just you're straight back into it because you've been through the trenches.
Straight.
Well, we are two minutes over.
Yeah, parting shot, Shawnee?
No, I was just going to say, now when I run into you, Killing, we worked on this together.
We did.
So we have this moment and this experience together.
So when we run into each other.
Piki Blinders, the immortal man in select theaters already March 6th it was.
And on Netflix, March 20th, I highly recommend this thing.
And you can't fold laundry watching it either.
put the laundry down,
tuck in,
and enjoy every frame of this thing.
Incredible work done by
in front of them
behind the cameras.
It's just,
it's a stunning film.
Really.
Very kind.
It's lovely to chat to you guys.
I had loads of questions
to ask you guys.
Oh, let's start.
Get yourself a podcast and invite us on.
They're handing them out.
We haven't had a gossip.
Yeah.
Oh, we got to gossip all day long.
You can gossip after I leave.
Yeah.
Such a pleasure to meet you.
What a pleasure.
Been a big fan for a long, long time.
Such a big fan.
Yeah, same, such a big fan.
Likewise, guys.
You're the man, Killian.
Lovely to chat to you all.
Yeah.
We'll do it again.
Enjoy your evening.
Get your slippers on.
Thanks.
All right.
Bye, guys.
Yeah, it's nearly bad time now.
All right.
Bye, buddy.
Good night.
Bye-bye.
Bye.
Well, there he is.
And you know, the most remarkable thing about his talent,
that accent, completely fake.
He is actually from, yeah.
Yeah.
No kidding.
Yeah, can't in Ohio.
Why would he?
Can't in Ohio.
Yeah, his dad actually was one of the people that helped build the NFL Hall of Fame.
Oh, that's amazing.
Yeah, yeah.
No, this is a character he hasn't dropped for years.
Wow.
I mean, that's deep.
That's amazing.
Deep, deep.
So, wow.
What a fella.
You know what?
Yeah, he's so good.
Christopher Nolan and him, like, you kind of think of those two together.
And I was trying to think of who else are there.
There's a lot of them, like, Tim Burton and Johnny.
Depp
Yeah, Leonardo DiCaprio
and Martin Scorsese.
Sure.
Yeah.
Did he really
Scorsese.
Yeah, and Tom Hanks
and Spielberg did a bunch
didn't they?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's one of them.
Here comes a joke, right?
I thought that was leading to a buy,
but no, that was a real observation.
It was.
He was being sincere
while he searches for a buy.
Where do you go?
Is there a buy website?
I do have a bunch of
of buy thing.
but
boy
Will you're showing
a lot of restraint
not doing any of the
by jokes at all
I know
shoot
oh
that's a good
Sean
oh Sean did you
Sean did you key it on one
did you get on
oh
what could be
you know
I hope
I hope the movie
I can't wait
to see the movie
of our guest today
that's great
what's it called
it's called
Peaky Binders
Smartless is
smartless is
100%
organic and artisanly handcrafted by Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarf.
Smart. Less.